even if I was to have unprotected sex I
could not pass the virus on to anyone
else essentially You could argue that
it's safer to have sex with me someone
who's undetectable than someone who
doesn't know their status and isn't
getting tested because you don't know
whether or not they have it whether or
not it's being managed whereas I know
concrete that I cannot pass it
on Hello my name is Kyle and I am a HIV
activist and semi-professional drag
queen today I'm going to be opening up
this box and answer and some confronting
questions about
HIV what is the difference between HIV
and AIDS so this is a big one HIV
doesn't kill you HIV attacks the immune
system so the virus makes its way into
your bloodstream and it attacks the
white blood cells and reduces your CD4
count which is essentially the cells
that actually fight all of the things
that your immune system needs to fight
and back in the the day when we didn't
have the medication readily available
they would attack the cells to a point
where you would be weak and frail and it
would develop into AIDS which is then
what would kill people and your immune
system would be so weak that you know a
common cold would like really really
affect you the common misconception is
that if you have HIV you have AIDS
that's not the case I have HIV but I am
on medication and I am managing it
therefore I will never get Aid so long
as I keep taking my medication meaning I
should have a full healthy happy
life is it mostly gay men that have HIV
a common misconception is that HIV is a
gay issue which is probably due to the
media back in the day demonized in the
gay community so it was widely reported
as a gay plague um when in actual fact
anyone is susceptible to HIV if you have
unprotected sex then you put yourself at
risk I think initially it became more of
a queer issue because obviously gay men
were not using protection because they
were not worried about pregnancy so it
was always more of a heteronormative
thing to use protection in general and
it probably is mostly gay men but it's
not solely gay man it's anyone's issue
okay oh what a topical question if we
share food drink Vape that's so 2023 if
we share food drink or vape would I get
HIV no contrary to what the media used
to say no um it can't be transmitted
that way you are not at risk if you know
anyone who's HIV positive you can just
be completely normal with them you can't
get it from any of those
things can you transmit HIV through
kissing someone no that is a myth you
cannot pass it from a kiss you can pass
it from penetrative sex unprotected sex
and you can pass it through sharing
needles but just in case you are not
going to contract
HIV would you have a one night stand yes
I only have one night stand but um I
personally I am on medication and I'm at
a point where my viral load is
undetectable in my blood so we call that
U equals U which means undetectable
equals untransmittable therefore even if
I was to have unprotected sex I could
not pass the virus on to anyone else and
not only that I have learned through
some training and stuff that I've done
over the years I'm not morally or
legally obliged to disclose my status to
anyone if I am undetectable essentially
You could argue that it's safer to have
sex with me someone who's undetectable
than someone who doesn't know their
status and isn't getting tested because
you don't know whether or not they have
it whether or not it's being managed
whereas I know concrete that I cannot
pass it on so yes I'm not going to curb
my sex life just cuz of HIV have I ever
felt ashamed um yes in the beginning
it's a it's a long journey to get into a
point where you feel at peace with it
yourself so I had a lot of the cliche
reactions when I was diagnosed it was
like oh my life's over I'm never going
to have sex again how do I tell people
but I think if you get to a point where
you just you know look at it as
something that is just a condition you
take a tablet every day to manage it
but you are not a lesser person because
of it and that is easier said than done
but I'm at that point so that's great
but yeah I have felt shame both from
myself and other people over the years
because some people are ignorant but
it's a wasted energy to be ashamed of
yourself in any capacity especially
something like an SCI which can happen
to anyone what are the main symptoms of
HIV now this varies case to case I
didn't have any symptoms I just happened
to find out from an STi test that I had
it um which I just kind of took on a
whim I didn't go because I thought I had
it but you can get a lot of different
things such as nausea sickness some
people start feeling fatigued and really
like lethargic all the time um it can
manifest itself in rashes and SS but it
truly is Case by case it's not a one-
siiz fitall approach so if you're
feeling ill or you've got a rash then
yeah it's worth getting checked out but
my advice would be obviously a use
protection but if you know you haven't
used protection that should be your
symptom you should be going to get
tested because you might never ever feel
any I didn't and then you might just one
day be like Oh I'm Ill so my advice
would be to treat every unprotected
sexual encounter as a symptom
essentially because that way you'll nip
it in the BD before it gets any worse
what is your life expectancy now back in
the day people used to get told oh
you've got x amount of months x amount
of years to live people would be put
into hospice it was a darker time but
thanks to the miracle of medicine today
it's not really the case anymore our
life expectancy is the same as an
average person and in fact in some cases
doctors have theorized that it might be
even longer because we're being checked
more regularly every 6 months I get 11
blood samples taken which nearly makes
me fake every time but it's worth it
because they come back to me they tell
me your viral load is undetectable
therefore I can't pass it on your CD4
count is at a healthy level meaning the
drugs are working and then also they'll
give you a sexual health screening every
time so every six months I'm getting a
text from my doctor saying your body's
all good and here's all the reasons why
most people don't do that and I know I
know that because before I had HIV I
would only go to the doctors if I really
felt like can e to like people get to
adult age and they sh their
responsibilities me included so yeah our
life expectancy is pretty much the same
like you're not told you will live for a
short amount of time now because of HIV
um how do I feel about the person who
gave me HIV actually with me I was
really careful with condoms I would have
protected sex pretty much unanimously
and I was in first year of uni and I was
having a lot of sex with different
people the person who gave me it well I
knew it was one of two people and I
messaged them both being very nice being
like I've just found this out you might
want to get tested because obviously one
of you was given me it um one of them
was really lovely about it and then sent
me a follow-up message
saying um oh yeah I've been tested I
don't have it but thank you so much for
letting me know I hope you're all right
exactly what you would want to hear the
other person was like you're disgusting
how dare you accuse me of having HIV
you're all of these awful things and my
my mind straight away was like so it was
probably you because you're so defensive
rather than being like thanks for
letting me know I'll get checked which
led me to believe it was him and then
when the other one told me he didn't
have it I was like okay it was you I
don't feel any type of way towards him
because one he was a one night stand and
I don't know him but two I see it as
kind of a good thing now like I've
arrived at a place where I think it's
given me a purpose so I guess thank you
is what I would say for like giving me
something to be passionate about and
like helping me find something that is
really like my calling almost so cheers
I
guess would you tell someone about HIV
on a first date or on your Dae and app
now this can be quite confronting for
most of us um because there is still
very much a lot of stigma there I I
don't tell everyone you usually if I
start to get to know someone a bit
better then I'm interested but also my
dating Life's a shamble so not really
the one to tell you about that on dating
apps grind have a really great feature
which is you can have your HIV status on
your profile so you have like what
you're into your age your pronouns and
that's one of the things you can put in
your bio it's a really good thing it's
really Progressive because what it does
is it normalizes HIV it's like if we all
just have our status on our files then
we're all acknowledging that it's kind
of a normal thing to talk about however
it can kind of have the reverse effect
because I don't have it on there always
a lot of people don't because what it
actually does then do is people just
block you because you have HIV people
will openly tell
you not interested in positive guys like
it can grinder and apps like that it can
encourage The Good The Bad and The Ugly
in every context so it's I think it's
really good and I appreciate that Granda
has it as an option I would tread
carefully having it on your profiles
make sure it's something you're
comfortable with and make sure you're
ready to potentially receive messages
that might upset you because not
everyone is as open about it as someone
like me how do you feel about media
portrayals of people with HIV and AIDS
well I could I could talk for a while
about this one if we if we go back a
little bit when people started getting
HIV and AIDS um it was obviously
affecting queer people first and
foremost and therefore it gave almost
gave the media an excuse to vilify and
demonize us as a queer community so
rather than it just being we hate the
gays but we keep it under wraps it was
like yes we've got them now we can post
headlines being like gay plague hits the
country all of this and it was intense I
mean there's lots of TV shows on it it's
a say there's lot you can watch to like
really get a gist of what it was like
but it was awful and the Ripple effects
of that are still here now so my
feelings on how it was portrayed then
are I'm disgusted I think it's abhorent
and I think the reason the stigma is so
prevalent today is because of that I do
think it's vastly improved you know each
Pride I feel like we see more and more
openness and openness but the more open
we are about it and the more the media
portrays it in a positive light kind of
makes the right-wing negative people
bristle a bit more so it does kind of
encourage more hate as well um but I
think we're moving forward in the right
direction how do you test for HIV and
what is the best way to test in the UK
so the best thing to do is always see a
doctor because they will test you for
HIV there and then but also coupled with
with that you get reassurance you get
information and knowledge that you might
not have if you're set at home alone and
should the test be positive you get
Comfort rationale things to read up on
and eventually medication and
essentially it is just a prick of blood
and when you do it in person there's a
little lipus paper and if a red line
appears you're positive I've never done
a postal kit but I believe it's the same
method just without a doctor Pres pretty
much it's pretty easy and also there's
like pop-ups and everything now you go
to Pride they do things at colleges I
volunteer with a charity called Skyline
and they're a support group that do
amazing work in Yorkshire and they go
around colleges giving out tests and
stuff like that or you can get tests on
the spot at the store so it's really
easy don't live in ignorance do you tell
everyone you meet so in the beginning I
was very close off about it so I told
told my best friend told a couple of
other people and then for me it would
manifest itself in drunken outbursts so
I would like get drunk lose my
inhibitions and then I'd have a cry
about it to someone you know how we we
kind of all do that with our trauma a
little bit if we have something that we
don't tell everyone it can come out
whenever you're like under the influence
and that was kind of like how I would
tell people and like more and more
friends knew via drunken Outburst um but
now I'm at a place where it's not like
hi I'm Kyle I'm HIV positive but I do
tell people if it ever comes up in
conversation I'll be like yeah I have it
and here's some info on it I have this
tattoo which is about my HIV and it's
supposed to signify like cutting the
ribbon of AIDS it's based on a Keith
Herring art now that's relevant because
people will always be like oh what's
your tattoo is it a tarot card and I'm
like no and then I have to explain what
it is so I've kind of branded myself
with it now at the point it's on my
forarm people do ask me what my tattoo
is or people idly mention HIV whenever
that happens I now just see it as an
opportunity to educate people but I'm
also very confident in myself and I'm
very sure of my opinions and my stance
on HIV so you know not everyone feels
this way some people don't tell anyone
but it's all about just assessing
whether you think someone is going to be
accepting or not and if you think you
can educate them or help them learn
change their opinion then go for it and
try but so you do have to protect
yourself so some people will just never
get it and I'm I'm thinking you know a
lot of older people closed mind of
people some people's minds won't be
changed but if you feel confident doing
it you should always try I think because
you'll be surprised at how like
open-minded people are but yeah I pretty
much tell anyone now if it comes off
then you're getting a
lesson and yeah that's all of them
that's it